hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the convenience store now
this is a horror game but it's supposed
to be a different experience more about
the idea of being alone working at a
convenience store when things go
disturbingly wrong but before we get
started I just wanted to say there is
the new invisible hearts collection
available at cloak brand calm if you
want to get yourself some sweet
invisible heart club related clothing
that is super comfortable check it out
link is in the description below cloak
brand.com now the convenience store this
might be a longer experience I actually
have no idea but I'm totally in it for
the full ride here I want to see it to
the end and if there's multiple endings
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to get
to them today but I will do my best to
see this through to the end o always
plain is we playing Wii in its time need
to get ready for work
do I oh my well this is not what I was
expecting I don't know why but I was
expecting something more along the lines
of kind of like us okay alright
slept well aha that is a cute thing
whatever that is change clothes Shh I
don't know if I'm freaking myself out or
if this is inherently creepy there is
always something about a game that knows
well
I'm assuming that's where I would go to
wait it's dark outside right interesante
yeah there's always something about a
horror game that just knows its
atmosphere and owns it right away
Oh kitchen right here gotta bring
flashlights I imagine if I actually
spoke Japanese I would understand the
translation if it's completely accurate
or not
hello nope don't have to poop okay well
not yet anyway oh this is where the
flashlight is pick up flashlight yeah oh
that's not better that's not better I'd
say it's worse actually okay that's just
the door we don't talk about all right
off to work gotta go gotta go baby oh I
need to eat something change and bring a
flashlight well I got the flashlight
I got changed I guess I just gotta eat
something right helloo helloo Ridge here
how many fridges do I need whoa I love
it I love it pop it on the stove pop it
in the microwave
where is the microwave Oh warm it up
yeah sure I figure if I worked in a
convenience store I might get a discount
or something on the convenience store
items
well a purlin approach you have done
this first I would have known that if
I'd have known how to play this game but
they don't okay eat bento yeah sure
that is some delicious bento final a
thing or two about bento that is goddamn
delicious okay off to work I go heigh-ho
heigh-ho am I good whoa
all right you know I'll close my door
now you leave okay Rick you're buzzed
about say leave it open leave it open
please I don't lock it
I guess this neighborhood is
particularly safe and we don't need to
worry about such things
Wow running is running is odd okay not
sure what we're going for
ooh that is out what what that doesn't
seem very safe also this running is not
very fast here do I go here I do know
yes I do okay well this is uh I mean I
guess I am working the night shift at
whatever whatever um River place and I
guess I don't know too much about
Japanese neighborhoods but maybe the
architecture here and layout is pretty
normal and standard in maps it is and
maybe it always looks a little Silent
Hill esque in the middle of the night
just kind of mosey on my way because
apparently there's nothing else for me
to do to the convenience store there
might have been like a secret in the
neighborhood that I was supposed to get
that was gonna predict my fate oh there
you are baby I was expecting a loading
screen no you are literally the only
store outside of this town Wow
oh hi are you person hello hi how are
you you're the only other human I've
ever seen here well I don't like your
face I don't like your face I don't like
your face I don't like your face okay hi
how's your face not good I know it
really happened here I was called to
warn you all by the name I cannot speak
of the day of judgment will
come okay cool good hey that's great I
don't like your face something wrong
with your face I don't like that face
okay cool
Bing bong hey hey your face is no
nevermind it's not so good
markiplier is that you big fan how you
doing oh god you made it hmm oh no it's
just that I recently heard someone had
fell off the bridge you just crossed
there was an old lady that said she saw
a man walking down the street with his
legs completely bent the other way
that's not a good thing scary stuff if
only this was a true story ha ha ha
sorry great good good joke man good show
whoa oh that's me okay it's really
bright in here you know oh maybe my
second thing I rarely buy magazines but
I do by Austin Lee magazines okay good
to know about you it's great
hello anybody in here thank you for
always keeping the toilet clean oddly
convincing all right Robbie
carrot juice I've been drinking only
that recently highly recommended by who
for who hello back room well this don't
seem too good why am I here no do I work
here is this actually a thing like I I
work here Oh what is this Oh No okay I
don't mind me I'm just getting used to
the area here before I have to be thrown
into the deep end of this horror show
and then die so I'm just doing the
customed
okay car how you doing Hey good great
okay well everything is looked Rabi
carrot juice okay good great everything
is looking good in the back boss
everything's looking good in the back
looks like summer expired well
have no not my job not my job
sung Q's choice hey I'll give it a try
if sungkyu says looks like summer
expired enter counter yes oh hey this is
not your best angle Madhu
hey how you doing neither is this to be
perfectly honest sorry okay you're sorry
all right sure I think some food are
expired by the time you start your shift
can you take them off the shells for me
your manager punch in
yuppers poppers cup lunker's okay
sanitize my hands look at the computer
you CCTV oh no no that's not going to be
good Oh who's in Oh bye okay bye I guess
you're out of here then okay well I can
move it that's great good to know
oh hi oh hi hey what's going on over
here uh alright I guess I better get out
of here uh all right
hello good meet you uh how are you I
didn't say Oh
can I help you don't mind me you're
gonna follow you around it's nothing too
bad I'm just gonna need to pull hey how
you doing can I help you alright
it's gonna take these items off the
shelf hey you want something buddy you
want oh [ __ ] are you out just don't mind
me I got to run down to the back I gotta
run into the dumpster wherever the
dumpster may be no mommy don't mind me
oh [ __ ] chickens off the shelf you know
it baby you know it baby
alright cool uh I don't know where to go
for this [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
dump astir dumps T trash it oh yeah
trash him I don't know if there's like a
high score for actually doing all this
properly and then I probably Oh God I'll
be right with you sir I will be right
with you
I will be right with you don't worry I
will do right by with you I will be
right by with you I will do right by you
sir sir sir did you run off with those
items sir ah yes sir yes yes sorry sorry
sorry sorry sir sorry sir I'm here I'm
here I'm here
hello hi may I have your thank you come
again see round buddy buddy you buddy
baby boo boo okay whatever
gotta go gotta go gotta go all right
cool uh uh see these are fine these are
fine these are fine we're all of these
fine looks fine looks fine
you look fine 13 bucks an hour night
shift this is the reason why I'm here
yep bruised peppers good stuff good
stuff good stuff I got an achievement I
don't know if that means I got all of
them either way this is a real nice
convenience store but only because I'm
here because I'm great at being
convenience store clerk okay ooh
who's there who's there what what wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait what what's
happening what what's the words
happening oh [ __ ] what's going on here
what's that hello sir how are you doing
sir bring me food or you will receive
eternal punishment okay okay you want
food dude dude module all I've got is
the expired food I guess I threw it away
instead of giving it to you I didn't
know it was an option so
okay good
oh I'm leaving I guess why did I leave
that's why that's why hello hello hi how
are you good to see you hey how you
doing hey would that for me love your
face yes it's kind of late for a
delivery man at this time huh we've
recently incorporated this system
exclusively for convenience stores that
are open late at night looks like this
package is directly shipped to the store
oh and the name matches your tag I think
this is for you
great great exposition yeah I'll take it
take it home take it home take it home
take it home home why would I take it
home it's not not anywhere near for my
shift to end why would I take that home
I guess that's the only thing I can do
with it
[Music]
oh why am i home oh this is not a good
idea oh it's not a good idea oh this is
not a good idea
watch closely yeah watch really closely
oh this is so not a good idea oh this is
not a good idea
oh is that all
nothing to it there's nothing in the
mighty wave great guess I'll just be on
my way
alright dude see round zero
Oh now is the first night oh now is
first night it's much darker than it was
before
oh it is much darker oh it is infinitily
darker oh it's so much darker okay but I
remember the path I remember the path so
what was that about a man with a
backwards legs that was on this bridge
what about a man who was backward leg
man on the bridge bridge of backward leg
man I wanted to give the guy food but I
didn't know that I needed to give him
food before I got into this whole mess
because why would anyone I've assumed
that that's something that needed to be
done hey hey so I heard you reported
that the doors would open on their own
well we got a guy to check the sensor
and it seems like the wirings were loose
no you thought it was some sort of
poltergeist I see those on TV all the
time but they're all scripted ghosts
aren't real after all you ignorant [ __ ]
could you think something like that how
could you even suggest it you never
talked to me again
who woods these oh I am what oh there's
probably some instructions I should
probably just go to the back room and
get the instructions for the day I
imagine this is like a pest control
thing all right what are we gonna hey
Manny G oh no I can't do it cuz I've got
this in my hands Oh someone goofed up
the trash can
oh did the guy did the guy do it to get
to the food I don't know I don't know
but I've got a pest control doodad
persecuted drop item oh you're right I
saw some rats buying the store someone
must have left the garbage bin open the
first person see this no it has to get
rid of the rodents
all right makes sense that right you got
it you got it you got it all right see
you around
dick well you didn't see the note no no
I didn't see the note weird about that
all right I'm off to kill some rats I
guess all right rats yes anybody else
hear anybody making a mistake of
existing here
I was not on my watch yes good good
great great excellently Darfur wonderful
wonderful wonderful wonderful this is
this is incredible
death feels all right good good great
great great great oh sorry bud hello
welcome welcome welcome to the
convenience store that is this hello why
Oh ma'am ma'am ma'am
Oh ma'am Oh ma'am ma'am ma'am ma'am
ma'am
Maura ma'am oh my god ma'am ma'am ma'am
ma'am ma'am ma'am ma'am can I help you
please I help you
oh man a little too close for comfort
there all right ma'am you have a good
day ma'am you have a good day ma'am here
for you if you need me service with a
smile that's how I be all right okay you
let me know if you need anything ma'am
ma'am you take care of yourself and your
cankles thank you I always glad to be of
service to the elderly someday we'll all
be old we got to make sure we do do
right by them all right good
very good very good very safe very
secure in here very secure oh how does
it go away
oh hi hey I'm in a hurry now could you
please fetch me five cans of beer and a
pack of cigar hurry up uh apparently
this is my job okay okay all right five
five packs of beer and a cigar feed I
would think in the droped one poo oh
okay there okay one
one it's really wet what I gotta do a
lot of it uh hey I'm in a hurry
uh yeah I got I got I got it apparently
this is my job if you were in a hurry
you do it yourself I guess but you know
whatever
I've never barged into a convenience
store and asked them to go get me
something but you know that alright
there's that all right here we go boy
you got it buddy
good now scan jiminy Christmas all right
cool
good is that old lady like dead in there
or something or what's the UH what's the
what's the deal uh all right
sketch you later where did that lady
drive in hi ma'am how are you where's
Ken Koon you know where Ken goodness I
thought I heard his voice this was my
daughter's house what did your doll oh
dear yeah uh okay whoa whoa lady lady
lady whoa whoa lady wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa lady lady lady lady are you coming
after me
so what's happening are you coming you
coming to get me or are you leaving lady
lady lady lady lady lady lady I am ma'am
ma'am ma'am all right okay all right
good good talk good Wow fluster II know
that clean that out and lady just weak
to devastation on it I love this
neighborhood and the people in it really
brings joy to my work oh hi hello is
this another delivery late-night
delivery for me I love a late night
livery hi I've been looking forward to
your delivery so badly come in come in
come in welcome to my store we've got a
great discount on Pringles come on in
you're welcome anytime
hello do you have something for me
would you like a steamed bun good to see
you again good to see you too I always
love return customers oh you know the
unstoppable trend on ordering everything
online anyway there seems to be a
baggage that needs to be picked up here
I don't see it
oh is it this one you're welcome come
again
we've got discounts on Pringles I love
my job any customers sneaking around the
court customers where are you yeah good
great just me oh boy the time flies when
you're having fun no food today no food
today but hey it's raining that's not so
bad
get on Brella of course get flashlights
I'm sorry did someone just tried to
unlock the Oh
open it yeah well close the door open
the package okay you know that's let's
wash it closely very closely let's watch
this closely hopefully it doesn't take
me long I want to get back to my job
love my job all right
not really showing me much okay all
right cool see you around the bend good
thing too Sunbrella one of those hats I
just stick on my head so I don't need to
use a hand on it it's awfully convenient
anyway it's time to skedaddle off to
work another day another dollar
Wow Kevin keV keV keV keV keV Kevin keV
Kevin I'm just gonna clock in right away
I'm just gonna clock in just gotta clock
in ah [ __ ] criminy hi Kevin oh I got
you good huh
yeah okay okay fine I'll stop I promise
I won't do it again okay cool good job
Kevin
some products were missing on this shelf
always keep the shelves full that's our
motto
please restock them by tomorrow morning
your manager thanks Kevin Kevin thank
you you're such a delight and a smiling
face II love you I love you I love you
all right see you around tomorrow Kevin
if K is it raining in here is is that
what I'm seeing is it raining in here
running in here okay whatever all right
this must be what I saw a ride
restocking loved loved it love I love it
restock baby kaboom kaboom
right alright see you tomorrow Kevin keV
sir
Kevin man keV keV keV where the hell
does this go keV Meister Cavallini
Kevlar All Right see ya I would think it
would go here but it's not letting it go
there alright maybe this is the wrong
item drop eggs completely shatter it on
the ground the door
[Music]
Oh who there who dear who did who did
who did that tell it car coming in hey
how you doing hey come on in
it's raining out there what are you
doing in the rain hello how are you you
look fun dr. painter
what are you hi I'm Hamada so there's
something wrong with the air
conditioning your boss seemed desperate
and keeping the food fresh hate to be
working this late but he pays me well
you know don't mind me I'll just quickly
check it outside units and head right
out I'm going to figure out where the
hell this thing I'm just guessing it
doesn't go anywhere but I'll just drop
it right there that's probably good
enough for anybody
sure was weird about that whole
door-locking thing though that was
bizarre huh oh oh oh ooh did you see
that oh no mr. man wait wait oh this bad
idea
oh this bad idea oh we use about to get
God oh no you're gonna get God I gotta
help him I better go help up he's gonna
get God he's gonna get God he's gonna
get not oh no something's gonna get him
he's gonna get God hello sir
don't get guy sir please hello
oh whoa I can just go here oh it's
locked
hello go man walk walk walk walk why why
why why why what what what what what
what what what huh what four four four
why am I here what happened to Claire
oven flapping it what happened to it
[Applause]
hate it hate it hate it hate it
oh no that's not it
oh that's normal totally fine
what a nightmare was it all a dream of
course of course it was of course of
course it was what is with this door
here the one that I haven't had that's
here and I can't out why's it there Oh
God about watching closely so closely
ah-ha-ha-ha wow wow wow that's great
I've already been there though so that
was old information I went back there I
don't know if I was supposed to go back
there but I went back there and so back
there is where I was I thought that the
air conditioner guy was going to get got
and so I wanted to save him I'm uh I'm a
hero
you know not all heroes wear capes some
wear headphones you know what I'm saying
and I just wanted to save that man from
getting got you guys at home know what
I'm talking about you know you know what
I'm talking about about saving very
altruistic very I'm just a goddamn hero
all right cap stirrer I am so ready for
you even though I hear other footsteps
besides my own out here I am ready for
you Kevin Meister where are you gonna be
where you gonna spook me ha Oh in the
claws of the game I punch in card where
would what my punching card to go maybe
it seems foolish of me to go punch in
when clearly I need to go to the place
in the back maybe maybe that's like the
obvious in okay okay all right well Oh
can't go out there home okay oh boy oh
boy
keep it clean oh boy who can't even get
out sound boy okay oh let me look at
this easy TV again
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha
no no no no no no no no no what do you
do is there who was the tiny child no no
no where you going tiny child who are
you going are you going tiny child or
what are you doing what are you doing
over there Oh interesting
you shopping you shopping you shopping
tiny child you shopping wait are you
actually in this wait or did you just
did I just not see you go buy tiny child
what were you looking at tiny child is
that important no no no this one it's a
signal I need to turn on the cricket yes
okay tiny child I trust you I trust you
okay where you going where you going
Oh interesting interesting interesting
which one you're looking at which one
you look at what are you looking at the
upper one you looking at the up you one
you looking at the upbeat I think you
were looking at the up you one yeah yeah
you definitely were looking I'll be up
you want okay I guess I just gotta do
this one at a time
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
oh wait is that the way is that the same
one or is that that's a different one oh
that's a different one okay so that's
that one next to that one yeah that
looks middle okay okay I think I got it
I'm not I'm percent sure but I think I
got him okay
okay oh can I not turn it off oh [ __ ]
okay okay you can only turn on so many
okay
[Music]
where did I get him
oh I think I got it oh hi how are you
hello hi who's there
hello Oh Oh bring home what I just
experienced was perfectly normal fourth
night of course of course the fourth of
course the fourth night okay did I get
it
No Oh Oh interesting
is this like a choice I could either box
it up put it or i'ma watch it I'm gonna
watch it I will watch it I will watch it
yeah
I'm sure I'm very sure very sure about
that I am 100% sure about that
100% that you know I don't like to see
that this is that thing that I don't
like I definitely don't like to see this
that's not comforting you hate to see it
yeah I hate to see it
Oh Oh is this my sleep paralysis demon
please don't kill me I don't want to die
I can't move I I can't move that's what
I was saying
great I got a marker right there hello
oh I see you I did i hi oh I'm done I'm
dead so I'm done Yin rings I'm dead and
a half alright well then that was quite
a game that was interesting that was
really interesting it didn't have many
of like the the big cup boom scares that
you would see in a lot of horror games
but that was really like unsettling the
whole way through
I liked that experience that was really
cool I liked that a lot
good stuff awesome stuff like it a lot
really cool so anyway that is the
convenience store there are other
endings as was evident by me getting
ending number two however considering
how long it took the plague to get just
get through to get ending that ending I
will take my chances
the only thing is like I don't know if
there was any obvious indication of what
ending would get to what of like
watching these videos would end up with
you dying which is uh you know already
interesting but I don't know what the
other ones would have done and if there
was like some indication of what that
was going to be you know what I mean I
mean curiosity kills the cat that's
obvious but was there more to it than I
missed out on I don't know if you want
to try it out for yourself
there's a link in the description below
also if you want to get the new
invisible hearts Club collection at
cloak brand comm go down in the link in
the description below go to cloak brand
come get you some comfortable clothes
today if you want to check out more
scary games I've got them down in the
description too and
the suggestive videos down there down
there thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]